[Music]
hello how's it going everybody the
camera is higher so i have to remember
to look up
so
um we are continuing with our
third french and we're hoping to also
finish the win over today so make sure
to
check the other two french's
on youtube
and
we are hoping i'm kind of hoping i'll be
able to touch a little on the second
part of philadelphia today too but
it's just an hour i can't do everything
so
um
let's keep the goal for finishing up
another
um
so
if you remember hopefully you do
um
we talked about
some of the weird lines last week and a
little bit of the queen c7 line let me
make sure my position is
there yeah so we talked about a bunch of
weird lines we talked about queen c7
which is also mainline to be fair and
you know we take and i gave you some of
the lego's recommendations some of my
own personal experiences
and
i also kind of touched upon
you know for example what if they don't
take right now what if b6 or what if 97
first and so we kind of had that going
um
so i did not talk about castle i do know
that
so i'm going to talk about that a little
uh the idea is that
i will share some of my games like some
of my experiences something that works
for me with you
and we can kind of see if that's
something that you want to do or you can
take [ __ ] recommendation or you can do
something that
um
well you do i have great experience in
french
i think i had
two at least two games yeah sorry my
apologies that's my text message because
i want to like feel funny when i get
text but i don't want something boring
so
um
yes
uh
yeah so i've i had like two great
experiences with french
in u.s championship 2020 so
i haven't included those here because
they were
not exactly venomous
so but we're gonna stick with this
shores castle for today now um if you
have some
experience with it from the audience or
from the chat is this something you guys
play as white or black
i see a lot of heads shaking
i don't really see much
ah on the chat either
let me also refresh this
see if i can
mess it all up nope did not mess it up
good
all right yeah
so let's talk about this then
um
after queen g4 there are a bunch of
stuff black can do
but castle is one of the main two that's
something that i'm going to be talking
about a lot now i really like this
bishop d3 because with bishop d3 you are
kind of setting up
the ideas for attack
so uh some of the things you want to
remember is because of this pod
structure
we do like it because you know how
closed off it is
uh we do like having this diagonal
because it definitely is the strongest
place our bishop can be in there are
obviously weak squares here but we can't
really
get to them just yet because of the pawn
structure we could consider some sort of
these attacks not just yet but
because the center is super close we
could consider doing king side attack
with our palms without having castle so
i have a bunch of games where i just you
know left my king in the center i
brought the king to d2 now some of the
weaknesses that our position has is well
this pawn you know it's very attackable
um so that's something you do want to
keep
and touch
when you're thinking about you know what
do i want to do the other part is so we
said that we want to do a king side
attack right so we should always kind of
keep in mind what what about f5s that's
one part the other part is you know if
black tries to also come up and do a
queen side attack with their pawns so
there is a bunch of stuff you have to
think about both as
what is some of the benefits what are
some of the things you want to watch out
for
so
uh i just mentioned f5 so let's actually
talk about f5 what do you think we
should do should we um or should we move
the queen
oh now i find now i understood the chat
chat is coming in from the top that
makes more sense
okay i'm used to youtube chat when it's
you know the new one comes from the
bottom this makes more sense
thank you different yeah i forgot yeah
see the thing is if you don't jump us on
you have to move the queen which means
your bishop kind of got blinded and the
opponent gained some control over their
king side so yes you kind of have to um
possum rook takes now what
i'm sorry
that is true yeah
but right now black could have ideas
such as e5 to try and gain more control
over the center and poke or clean
so what do you think we should do
do you if you can read that far you have
a little bit of advantage
compared to the online
queen might audience to get out of the
discovered attack
well that's a big mite um you know
something like queen h5 to threaten on
the h7 score is possible but opponent
could easily play h6 and stop it
how about h4 are you still hitting that
and the rook tank come over and be
fitting
still punish six
g5 yeah bishop g5 makes a lot more sense
too because you're you're developing and
you're also attacking the rook and
you're kind of pinning over here so the
either the rook has to move or they got
to do e5 now the problem with e5 is you
get queenish for attacking over here and
there so even if e4 then you just pick
this up and you're good to go
so bishop g5 is cool
after bishop g5 what if real close to
f7 this happened to me in a real
overboard game
a few years back and
um
i was trying to you know cross 2 300
trying to get my double gm i am norms
that that's the
notorious 2015. oh my god 2015 was so
dreadful i mean it was great but
my rating was going up and down and up
and down it was a it was crazy
where was this game played
if you can read this
this wasn't bl
and this is the apartment
big with 2g
really
well that's that's true but again they
want to do e5 so now your idea of moving
the queen away could be useful so queen
h5 so you start attacking over here and
you're forcing opponents to choose
to move one of these pawns
now my opponent chose to play g6 even if
they played h6 i don't have to move this
bishop because you're not going to take
this so i could simply develop over here
if you do take then i can simply take
back with the knight you know and you're
pretty toasty
so
um
let's say g6 now what would you want to
do with the queen
hint if you were here last week or if
you watched last week's video we did
talk about some of the um
weird maneuvers with the king with the
queen sorry
i'm seeing a lot of my usuals here but
see the problem is queen h6 it doesn't
it's not really threatening anything
so black can simply play c4 and you know
now you have to vacate this diagonal and
when you come back
then something like
uh
for example queen f8 could work but the
problem with queen f8 is now this end
game is much more desirable for us our
king is safe we have this really good
rook going this bishop is
very useless so this end game would be
much more beneficial for us
but instead of queen f8 something like
queen b6 would be interesting because as
i said this pawn is a weakness our queen
side is a weakness so this is a serious
threat right
so
now we're in a little trouble
so instead of queen h6
yes no actually no we don't want to do
anything more forcing because we can't
we want to we want to retrieve the queen
and start to come back to our queen side
because right now my queen up here isn't
really doing anything
and there's no attack there so i'm
listening
yeah
so
queen d1 kind of weird but make sure to
refer to last week's video because we
talked about
another cool slash weird idea like this
yeah
yeah exactly h pawn could also join
now after queen d1 if you do stuff like
this well that's great because you are
not you're no longer attacking much
stuff so let's say queen a5 now what
well give it some thoughts and let me
know
oh just developed a nine ninety two
ninety two is actually a pretty bad idea
maybe
knight two is not a good idea your
bishop gets trapped
that's right
but what if they eat your f2
yeah that's why you hit the f2 with the
rule you guys can't do that knight f3
yeah knight f3 feels kind of interesting
right because you're developing you want
to might want to jump up there even if
they do take it that's not a problem for
us because their queen gets extremely
misplaced
and we might not be able to trap it but
we are definitely making it go in a very
yes but that's not the point the point
is like it's not about our development
because my bishop would love to stay
here and doesn't have to you know go up
there or my rook isn't doing as much up
here as it was doing on i want the point
is that we made opponents queen go in a
very awkward position and it's very
attackable we can try to attack it this
way we can just let it be we can castle
if we want to
you got
three of black pieces are not developed
and all your pieces are good yeah 95
could also be quite interesting yep um
my favorite is just trying to eat the
queen if you can but if not that's also
pretty good
thank you
so
uh
unfortunately for me my opponent didn't
take over here
a very interesting line is this because
you can't take with the queen i mean
technically you could but now you have a
lot of trouble over here
so that's not something we would want to
do
if rook takes knight you kind of are
forcing to take out the pawn and the
queen can take here and this is falling
and it's it's a lot of troubles for us
so
black definitely does have some counter
play
and drip takes knight is one of the best
ways black can try to continue another
on another yes
his night was free when when he got
through doing all that
basically
that is true but um i was just talking
about the general position yes if black
let us we would definitely eat that
night
now so another great idea for black is
the c4
because um
yeah and when the bishop moves they take
it over here and they want to eat this
and the chat is being funny i like it
and a bishop d2 you kind of are forced
into doing bishop d2 now after bishop d2
they kind of have to decide what to do
with the queen and queen b2 is the only
safe spot
but
an interesting turn of events this
bishop can finally get into a very good
diagonal
and we are planning
yes we are kind of planning on
attacking the queen we might again not
be able to eat it but we are working on
it now
let me present another cool thing what
if night just comes out
what do you think we should do as light
[Music]
c
i'm sorry what's the line you're
suggesting
d captures uh
c5 and
then in this pawn structures you you
rarely want to do that if you do take
the problem is you leave these two pawns
hanging you know it's now an island you
give up the full control over the center
and the opponent can always continue
doing stuff like this
so taking in this pawn structure taking
is not a good idea
yeah castling is very comfortable but
the other thing is now because um we
already developed and this is no longer
at serious threats we could simply just
bring it back to
or queen d2
i went for queen detail but yes castling
is also completely doable
um
i went for queen d2 and as soon as
opponents played knight f5
i was thinking about okay so should i
take it or should i not because you know
it's if i do take it uh
there will be a lot of new weaknesses
for me to explore and technically my
bishop on d3 is not as useful anymore so
i could want to just get rid of that
bishop they could always also try to do
c4 but
this is a very important game for me so
i really wanted to win
and i went for something a little
different so what do you think white
should do
[Music]
and yes christian i believe that is it
and sorry i just say 95 yeah 95 makes a
lot of sense because after 95
you kind of either have to take it or
you got to move the rook right if you do
move the rook then i could kind of start
to attack over here potentially if take
we take back now yes the position the
pawn structure did change but uh the
interesting point is that now i have
locked your bishop in
so
that is another point yes so um that's a
very interesting
turn of events now my opponent played
bishop d7 still trying to get the bishop
out get the rook out and i started to
just
um go at their king
now the thing is i don't necessarily
need to castle
not just because it's french but because
um
the root might be more useful
exactly because of the semi-closed
center and opponent's inability to
attack my king and to open up the center
it means that i don't need to move my
king from the center now if they could
push and they could open up center then
yeah my king needs to move away and
that's something my opponent tried to do
they went d4 now what do you think we
should do
yes if the character will exchange
queens is that fine
mayu okay
so
after take
this is something i went for another
suggestion
it's more of an engine idea rather than
my idea is this visual f6 because bishop
f6
i guess computer likes it
but
i'm not that crazy i'm you know this is
i don't really mind exchanging queens
and if i can't avoid it i would
definitely want to not give up upon
and so okay let's talk about this
position
white definitely feels better not just
because of the um two bishops but also
because of this over here because of
opponents bad bishop because of another
semi-open file over here so we have a
lot of ideas but opponent's last move
was knight d4 which means they're
attacking our pawn so what should we do
yeah very logical king guitar is also
very doable but
um bishop 6 makes more sense opponents
were like bishop c6 again making a
different type of attack
then i went for
rook g1 this wasn't um the idea that i
was kind of hoping to achieve because i
wanted to really try and get g5 h5 and
um
yes
yeah but the problem is that they're not
necessarily going to be that cooperative
they could always play g5 and you know
if i take now i give my opponent some
counter play if i don't take then
they're still threatening over here so i
have to decide how to stop this so
i was hoping to avoid these kind of
messes so i was kind of keeping h5 and i
thought hey i'm always going to want to
do these so i might as well bring the
recover but that was not the most
accurate idea because opponents should
have
considered
doing c4 now
and after c4 if i do take then they can
start to
figure out some new ways of counter play
so that's kind of why um
rook g1 would be a much better idea rook
g1 was not that's much of a better idea
because i it was a very slow move and i
gave opponents a lot of new ideas
some
frogs in space is asking what variation
franchise is this is venover with castle
and after castle opponents went five
immediately it's a very sideline
okay
uh well i want to keep the rook here so
i can do h5 yeah but i mean
your g pod is it's pandora yeah that's
fair yeah i need to be able to um on pin
before i can do g4 yes you're correct
so uh my opponent did not play c4 but i
think c4 would have definitely been
very weird for me
yeah he went rock d7 so it's a different
type of counter play and
not necessarily they could still want to
play c4 right away because if i do take
knight f3 and pick this up
so um another idea that you could pick
up from this game not necessarily just
french is you know that idea of like how
interesting it is to put the rook in
front of a queen even if there's a bunch
of pieces in front of it or a rook in
front of a king again if there's a bunch
of piece in front of it i think that's a
very
um interesting way of
creating new threads for yourself now
after rook t7
i went to h5 because i had to choose
either move the king or push the pawn
and i was like if i move the king then
i'm giving in to what the opponent wants
so i simply went for h5 and now my
opponents played very good you entered
g5 and i can't really i don't have
enough time to take it because he could
what if you play c4 right away
instead of g5
well he could but even if i do take and
they go knight to f3 it's not that big
of a deal because i'm actually
threatening a bunch of stuff or actually
i could take this first
so this would be um i mean i would be
happy
so h5 was a definitely a nice way to
counter play
and after g5 now they do want to do this
though so i chose to just move the king
away h6 is also quite interesting
because you know i might be able to
bring the rookie or attack a little bit
more
but
it would definitely give enough time for
c4 and i really did not want to give my
opponent that many chances so i went for
king
c1 and i ate that
and see again my opponent is developing
with temple even if it's kind of like a
weird fake temples because he's not
technically turning my bishop just yet
but i have to be very careful about it
so
what do you think we should do here as
white should we move the bishop should
we ignore it and just um
maybe do stuff in the king side what do
you think
to
where where are you going
well
yeah the problem is that they don't care
about this night as much as about this
bishop if they could eat our bishop and
give up this night they would be very
happy with it so something like bishop
e4 centralizing the bishop
and attacking over here
would not be very fun for us
i mean we're not losing but we
definitely
lost the advantages
that makes more sense
bishop takes g2 and then
we can take the knight actually rope
takes knight
yeah well they're also taking our so we
would have to attack the bishop first
and yeah this would be the best way
opponents should have played but lucky
for me when i played rook d1 they
immediately wanted to defend this first
and also you have to keep in mind we've
been playing 25 moves
until here and we were both not in time
trouble but we were in time pressure so
we had maybe about 10 minutes each left
more or less
so
what do you think we should do with this
oh i like the hat
so what do you think white should do
while you're thinking i'm going gonna
take a minute and self-advertise
so um i have a mini simultaneous coming
up and
not next oh actually i was gonna say two
weeks but it's more like ten days now
the day after my birthday it's not
because of my birthday but i kind of
want to time it close by but now the
problem is i can't really celebrate the
birthday on a stage so i celebrate after
this
anyways on april 16th if it's in person
so you kind of have to be here but since
a lot of you are here already you might
as well grab a flyer and sign up it's
not going to be in the chess club it's
going to be in the pulitzer art
foundation i'm sorry if i miss pronouns
i've said it so many different ways i
don't even know which one is the correct
way
so yeah feel free to sign up
and
yeah i know there are 30 spots available
but i do know there are still a few
spots left so
thank you yep
that that link will doesn't
i actually have two students who came
just in town for this for the for the
pulitzer for the symbol so i mean
if you're close by you want to come down
i'm not going to stop you
it's a destination yeah
somebody wants to come with their
private jail jets with brazil oh i wish
i could explore brazil
i've been there but it wasn't you know i
was there for tournaments so
all right
back to chess
why to move
what do you think what
what did dorset do actually dorset
didn't do the best move so never mind
but what do you think is the best one
for the position
yeah that would be like who
who was
oh that would be the best move for the
position because you know you're moving
away your bishop you're um beginning to
attack something you're defending c2 it
makes a lot of sense but i went for king
b2 because
i was okay if they take it
i thought uh this is still going to be
enough counter play
and
i was kind of wrong
because
this is too messy
and if i was doing it right now like i
don't have advantage but neither does
opponent this is too crazy complicated
so um the problem is if i was playing
right now i would definitely go bishop
d3 because i want to avoid complications
i don't want any i don't want my
opponent to get funny with my pawns or
pieces so bishop d3 would make a lot
more sense because you would be
attacking h7 you would be defending c2
yes they could eat over here but even if
they do i can first of all simply take
this and sacrifice which i don't think i
would honestly i would probably go to g1
you move it then great now i can get
funny with your pieces
i do like this very much i have to say
so this is not what i did
and i want to try and wrap this game up
because i have another line i would like
to get to
but
uh
no it's too crazy my opponent started to
mess up he played rook b5 raps looks
like just look like such an innocent
move right
but the best move was either to push or
to take and open up my rook which is
crazy when you think about it
taking should not be the best move in
this position right because it just it's
crazy you give my rook the whole seventh
rank my other rook can join but the
problem is i don't have enough time to
do stuff like this because my c2 is
falling
and then you also get the second rank so
that's what i'm saying crazy chaotic
that's not what you want in a game
i actually know some people do i have a
student who like always chooses the
craziest openings i actually had him
yesterday so if you're watching um the
craziest openings that i've never seen
but he knows what he's doing so
i'm not gonna stop him but it's really
crazy
i try to avoid chaos i want more like
the the cobra style i want to take away
all your um all your hopes and dreams
and
go with that but some people really
enjoyed the chaotic and the tactical and
everything
so my opponents went to rook b5 i mean
king a2 you know but i kind of have to
and
in this situation there is only one move
to win what do you think we should do
try to avoid looking up there but if i
mean it's really hard if i was i would
but
don't take your glasses off maybe that
might be
i know nikki likes chaos
with the
um king's gambit oh boy
thank you alan
yeah wait
okay oh okay
um
instead of why can't i play with g7
first and then well because your rook is
defending your second rank if you do
play drug g7
then they can check check you
at least i said i think that's the best
to be honest
for black
so c3 was very crucial i'm very proud of
myself
yeah yeah
so your knight is kind of busted
and if you do move the knights well
let's say you move the night now i'm
going to check you
and
it's going to say check me to you but i
can't so
probably eat stuff
maybe chicken again no let's eat stuff
and your knight has to stay here to
defend which means my rook has enough
time to join and check me too
possibly yeah i mean i prefer the
checkmate but yeah that's another part
of it
so my opponent enter f3 my opponent was
taking your advice trying to promote
and i just went for
you know the good old eating to be fair
rook g4 is not the only move you could
have considered taking as well but i
really really really wanted to avoid
giving my opponent
any type of opportunity
so this would again be chaotic so i
didn't want chaos so i went to a rook g4
and i wanted to just eat if you take
great now my rooks are here i have some
serious checkmating threads
and my opponents tried to prevent it
which only meant i could bring more
pressure on this if you play f2 bishop
h4 that'll be another win my opponent
tried to defend it over here
now that i'm thinking about it e6 is
also interesting but i went for king b2
opponent move the rook now e6 uh he took
i took and with two pawns
in exchange for bishop this is winning
enough especially since now i'm
threatening to either eat that or
exchange rooks so my opponent just
resigned
but it was definitely one of my great
games and to be honest i had slightly
forgotten about it before today
that i had played this game i remember
the opponent but i didn't remember the
game it's been seven years oh my god
oh it's almost been 16 years since i've
been playing chess
my
yeah
my chess career is
like almost an adult
now good drive
my chest carrier can't drive
all right
let's go back to
something a little different knight d7
is the best one
back when
my opponent played drug f7
but knight d7 is indeed the best one the
thing is if you take it they'll take
back attack the queen you move the queen
wherever and now they get to attack you
again
and
um
thank you adam yes
and i can try to you know defend it but
then again whoops bishop knight e4
opponent gets a lot of momentum so
that's something that i didn't really
want to do
so
after knight d7 i would advise queen
asher actually leggy would advise queen
h4
and
kind of piling up over here
if h6 now you can consider taking but
you have to be very very careful with
how you play it
uh for example when i played it
in a real game i wasn't as careful as i
should have been on the game ended in a
draw now what do you think is the best
move for white's rights now
sorry
yes because black just took over here
knight f3 would be interesting but the
problems is that again queen a5 is
coming up c4 is still right there you
move the bishop boom knight e4 there's
still a lot of like black has a lot of
ideas that we ideally want to avoid
how do you feel about take
that's what i went for and it gave my
opponent some some nasty
ideas
it's doable it wasn't a bad idea but it
definitely made it more chaotic than i
would want to the best one is queen g3
which i couldn't remember during the
game
um
well you go here
since you have extra material you would
love it if you know you can exchange
stuff over and even if the knife gets
here perfect i've already exchanged this
bishop and that's the only thing that i
have to care about that's perfectly fine
all right so queen g3 was the best one
but i went for
um take an opponent got e5 and now it's
kind of forced into f3 to stop e4 and
knight f5 and you see you see how
chaotic it gets right for price of the
pawn
now why two what do you think we should
do
they're threatening c2
yeah also since the center is no longer
closed then it's very mobile we don't
want to do that
now i would play knight
i don't really care about
dropping this bomb i mean it's triple
pump so 92 yeah 92 would be interesting
um
but i feel like it's not just the
tutorials they'll definitely gonna eat
at least another one of these so that's
kind of where i really really
didn't want to give up the pawn but yes
92 would be a good idea
i started i i should have probably went
queen enough to or 92 but i got too
creative and i long castle
i did not lose this game
i should
yeah but my king is like up in the air
see back in 2014 15 16 i had a wilder
chess ideals
now i'm just like
the cobra style but now and you know
when i played this game it wasn't like
that it was the kill or be killed boom
yeah
that's not bad though because now
see yes you're correct so the best move
for black would be to play d4 first to
cut off the queen
which we kind of both missed
and we were both um what was i i was oh
my god i was
uh i was 2365 when opponents was 23 19.
so sorry
yeah actually i
don't know what's my uscf
but if if you take you've got to take
back with the pond and um
well well see if you do take queen a5
yes
yeah that's
yeah so this is very uncomfortable even
if you play knight e2 they can still do
this but we both miss this d4 idea and
opponents went queen e7 but i got queen
before an opponent had a comfortable
position but not that comfortable so the
game ended in a draw eventually
and i'm cutting it short because i
really do want to show you another
idea which is not f5 so we talked about
this f5 for quite a while which was
quite fun
but the main line is not necessarily a
five it's actually knight c6
and with knight c6 niggy had some really
great ideas which i think it was
published before his book came out on
chess base because i know i had i was
playing it before the book came out but
um i really do like this knight c6
because after 96 you do have to remember
your move order though i kind of once
messed it up and it was not pretty so
quinash five is very interesting
uh the idea is you still will you want
to check me first so they have to stop
the checkmate then you want to get the
night outs you still want to do
checkmate ideas now um
you also have to be careful because if
you let's hit black will try to play c4
they can't do it just yet because
your idea is
whoa whoa first sorry this
you want to get this
this would be ideal your bishop was in a
great place you're one upon voila so
it's important for black not to play c4
first
and
also they don't have to play something
like h6
they could simply play queen to c7 now
the idea is simple if you do the same
things now they do
sorry h6 if you do this they they no
longer have to take it with the rook but
they can take with queen and threat and
checkmate
right
so because they would be doing this
threat
you
can
again you should play bishop e3 first
now again if c4
do you think we can play knight g5 or no
does this work
queen takes after h6 knight f7 f7 well
the thing is they don't have to take it
anymore because in the initial case we
were attacking the queen but since the
queen is no longer there they could take
this first
and my knight is a little trapped too so
that that would be problematic
so um
you and after c4
in this specific case you are kind of
forced into taking
and after f takes queen g4 is very
interesting now black has a bunch of
ideas there is this a5 there sorry
there's this b5 there's some queen of
sevens
um
if i'm not mistaken bishop d7 is also
quite intriguing
but
i i remember this
friendly game that i played years ago
that my opponent kind of managed to get
the bishop over here and i really didn't
like it
but that was a
very longer process
um
in the chat
cosplayer without the k
yes you are kind of partially correct
but the problem is if you do that you
already lost the pace and you haven't
eaten it back so
yeah that would be a problem
um so after in this case my opponent
went b5 queen f7s again i would advise
you to check neggy's book because
i'm not really sure if i'm advertising
it but it really helped my chance so i
guess that's the great reason
um so this queen beast queen f7 would be
very interesting and there are a lot of
really cool ideas because yes the center
is closed yes you do not need to cast
those you can do king d2s but at the
same time you have to choose how you
push these pawns because you can't just
start with h4 you or you could you could
start with knight g5 um if i'm not
mistaken because it's been a little
while since this position has happened
to me there was a very interesting idea
that you leave the knight over here and
sooner or later you're gonna try to go
f4 move the queen away go g4 and start
that attack
so that is and if they attack your
knight your knight will simply jump back
to h3
um so that is one way to consider it the
other interesting idea
would be
to start off with for example h4
you could start with knight h3 as well
but
again when you go f4 you have to think
okay where do you want to put the queen
then you go g4 are you going to go
actually at five or you're going to just
keep it around here and just push the g
and f g and h pawn so there's a lot of
factors to consider
so that's kind of one of the reasons i'm
leaving
this up to you for you to design because
i can't really decide for you but there
are a lot of great material out there
including the next book so make sure to
check that out
i'm sure there are fun stuff on youtube
too actually i don't know if a lot of
the most of the youtube videos i've seen
unless it's something that goes this
deep or like those video series they
don't really get as deep in the openings
they just give you like traps or like
general ideas but
so
yeah another reason i like to do these
um
video series is to
get as deep as i guess end games
so uh in this specific game my opponent
played b5
against me
and
to be fair i had this prepared
i always do if i know who i'm playing
so uh
that's why you should also join me on
tomorrow's prep like a pro i'm gonna
show you some of my favorite
preparations
i don't usually do that class but
tomorrow i'm subbing so make sure to
join
i believe seven yeah 7 30.
all right so h4
um again queen f7s are a very good idea
for opponent to do but in this case my
opponents kind of delayed their queen
movement
um they went for rook five now
what do you think we should do
um
tessubukura that's also an interesting
choice i tried knight d2's i tried e5s
but i and again my french wasn't as
great until i saw the um
leggy book back in 2014 or 15 actually
can't recall what year was it
so you saw it
um
a grandmaster wrote a book about
french car how to play against french
karakan and philadelphus like this thick
and then he wrote a bunch of extra books
about how to play against sicilian so
his name is perimer john negi
so
i read that book and i really liked
playing against french and i have a
really good score against it so it's
kind of
some of the lines that he includes his
book i'm talking about here and my
experiences with them
i know the club was selling it but i
think they're out of it since i started
um talking about it
but
it's well written it's simplified
um well it's
i read it when i was already 22 2300 and
it still had a lot to offer for me so
if you do read it regardless of your
level and you will have a great
understanding of french slash carl con
and pierre
philidor sorry not pirk
as white right yes
if you're looking at something
as black
another friend of mine
wrote another great book
two years ago actually for black as how
to play caro con and it's very in-depth
everything is really great my brother
who's 2400 read it and loved it and
yeah i don't think we have it here
though
but what was the name of the first one
the first book um if you look up negi
books
yeah
the first one is the french versus
french
white versus french karakan and philidor
and it was really great
okay where were we
oh yes
um so another there are two really cool
ideas here one of them is knight g5 one
of them is this queen h3 then g4
what's the point after knight g5 i
didn't see that like what was the threat
that we're making
well
for starters um in this specific game i
wanted to sacrifice the knight so i want
i went for h5
telling you i had a very sharper side
before
well i just feel like i was just
thinking
like you were saying bishop d7 edition
e8
why after knight g5 after like bishop d7
i didn't see
well something like bishop d7 now h5
your pieces are not in time
but if you did play h3 and if i did move
the knight then something like queen f7
to stop h5
and then yes
that could happen well black would be or
rightish
i'm very biased when it comes to french
so
especially vinover stainless is a whole
different situation
uh so
my opponent actually ended up playing h6
when i got ashfam i was very happy about
that
however uh queen h3 is also very
interesting because you start to set up
shop for a different type of pawn attack
and since the rook is out here this
would work better
um
that's kind of why queen f7s are more
desirable because not only it stops h7
but you know you could try and get queen
at five as black
so
appointed one rook of five i think i
should have went queen s3 i went knight
g5 because i was well i wanted to chaos
um
and my opponents did not accept to take
it just yet if they took that would be
great for me because you know i get the
full
file i can do queenish files i can do
god knows whatever i want honestly
um so opponents went quinoa seven which
was a good idea
and here i should have retreated the
night but i was not ready to do that
because i thought well what if they take
and i didn't really want to leave the
attack but it's not
i'm not necessarily leaving the attack
i'm simply switching my
attackers i'm switching pawns out for
actual pieces because i'm no longer
going to be moving these palms for a few
moves but i am going to try and get the
knight out and start attacking over here
so this would have been much more
pleasant
but
i went for f4 again i i really wanted to
make it a huge chaos
and my opponents played queen eights
which was again a great idea they should
not be taking it just yet because if
they do take now this is completely
winning for white
so she went queen eight i simply moved
the coin away which was a good idea in
this situation because if i move the
knights then i'm going to lose my pawn
and that is not going to be very fun for
me
and i have to move the queen again
so
i went queen h3
i'm setting up shop for if you do take
right
an opponent took on h5 now
i had to retreat and i did
but see if i had to retreat it would
have been better to retreat back here to
go to h3 and then jump to f4
rather than push
pushed upon to f4 and then retreat to f3
and then potentially h4 so that would
have been better
now um after knight f3 my opponents went
97 i got the king out
um again knight sword was probably
slightly better but i really wanted to
make the king safer
see yeah the black position is beginning
to look solid but the problem with
black's position is that it's too wobbly
opponent has to be very very precise
whereas i can play a few moves
not as accurate and still hold a lot of
attack so opponents should have played
queen f8 or queen f7
and had some potential ideas for take
again i say potential
but the problem is that actually not the
problem good for me
opponents with knight g6 which meant i
get g4
now after g4 uh up one is pretty toast
she took i moved the coin correctly she
took and
i took that guy if she ends up taking
here now
come on brooke where are you
yeah come here yeah
now i can enjoy this
so she didn't she played h5 and i simply
followed my knight at 4 and i got a
really great attack and extra material
so i was very fond of this position
now all i have to do is bring my pieces
over there
start piling up don't pay enough
attention to over here and do a
beautiful sacrifice
she couldn't have really taken it in
good conscience because well
um this is almost checkmate
so she played rookie seven okay seven
try and guard a little but
with having an extra pawn
this was too good
in this case i went knight f7 which was
really cool honestly but i feel like
queen g6 would have been even better
but i didn't go for that
um
this is too crazy
i mean it's great but
i feel like knight f7 was was enough
crazy
so yeah this was a great this was a
really cool game that i wanted to show
you
we are kind of done with the vinover the
only other line that i do want to just
briefly mention
which is not the short castle
is keep in mind we did talk about 97s we
did talk about early queen c7s we also
talked we talked about queen so now
castle now
uh we didn't really talk about knight
a5s knight f5s are take so the thing is
just remember if take
you can play bishop d3 and convert it
into the
lines that we talked about last week
with queen c7
so about queen c7
i much rather not take it because
everybody do so everybody knows it i
want something a little different so i
usually go for bishop d3 i have tried
queen g7 and it's really great but
bishop d3 is what maggie wrote that's
what i did that's what i love make sure
to read it do it
it definitely confused a lot of my
opponents
and um the other thing is this knight f5
yeah this knight the f5 i never really
liked it i mean i had great results in
it but i don't really love it because it
kind of stood against a lot of the
things that i wanted to do
but the thing is castle now and i'm very
comfortable already opponents should be
trying to you know play h5 make sure my
queen moves and try to exchange queens
this would have been a very interesting
try for black but black would also lose
a lot of their counter play because this
pawn is weak my king is in the center if
you're exchanging queens then that's no
longer
that's great for them so with that we're
going to take a tiny break and come back
and analyze your games so make sure to
have your games ready send them in the
chats don't forget it's supposed to be
on leachat's link format
and all right see you in a little bit
only on twitch
only on twitch
[Music]
you